you're about to watch this kid try to
make 20 million dollars selling nfts but
that's in a few hours right now he's
panicking because someone has accused
his project of being a scam and he's
come out to say he's innocent um i woke
up to some crazy fight about me some
weird accusations not sure where they
come from or how i'm tied exactly i have
no bad intentions i will never hurt
anyone physically financially or
mentally it's not in me i'm all about my
morals all about his morals well i'll
let you be the judge of that because
there's more to this story behind the
face of this kid in braces sits a group
of nft scammers in the shadows one name
for this group the nft factory and we're
exposing them today you see this kid on
camera is just a stooge set up to play
the part of a founder by those lurking
behind the scenes and what's worse is
that they've done this before except
this time the stakes are higher than
ever they stand to make 20 million
dollars on this scam but not if we can
help it so buckle up because this is the
10 million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla the internet detective and
welcome to another investigation
now our story begins with a project
called squiggles i know that sounds like
the name of a children's band or
something but it's not it's an nft
project that appeared to be the next big
thing it had a ton of hype around it but
right before it launched something
happened that threatened to make it
worth nothing at all a 60-page dossier
dropped hours before launch that alleged
that the founder of this project
squiggles isn't the founder at all but
instead a paid puppet it alleges that
the real people behind squiggles are a
group that has been going around
creating scam after scam and the
question is is that true well today
we're going to find out in order to do
so we have to talk about a group of l a
wannabes the main suspects being these
three
gabe gavin and ali now i'm intentionally
going to leave their last names out of
this report because i think one of them
is in high school because you know gotta
start early on that scam grind but let
me say fellas if you're gonna do this
and scam people you really should hide
your identities better instead of flex
on instagram just a free tip from me but
basically this dossier meticulously
documents over 60 pages allegations of
these three being behind not just
squiggles but several nft scams
including league of sacred devils league
of divine beings vault of gems sinful
souls dirty dogs lucky buddhism covered
faceless and on and on and on now
obviously i'm not going to go through
all these 60 pages but to summarize it
basically these guys churn out nft
projects that have the appearance of
trust and quality and then after
launching it turns out they're just cash
grabs the way they do it is by setting
up projects that all seem unrelated and
run by a bunch of different people but
aren't they're run by mostly the same
people and it's a big racket for example
here's one of these guys gavin he's
publicly admitting to running the
project sinful souls hey we're the
owners of sinful souls and we're here in
l.a at one of the biggest nft and crypto
mixers to date but then behind the
scenes he's also caught in projects
where he's not listed such as this one
which was called faceless here he is
discussing with another co-conspirator
whose identity they're going to use as
the face of this thing quote obviously
centurion is gabe so do you want me to
list him as the owner of the site yeah
travis might be doxxed as centurion lol
then when talking about who should be
listed as the advisor marketer and
artist gavin says well make it up he
gives an example of what he means quote
hello i am a 3d artist for this project
i've been creating art for the past six
years and it is my first time that i am
working on nfts when i am creating art
i'm always thinking of a quote from
frank camaro people ignore designs that
ignore people and that is really
powerful when you grasp the meaning wow
these people are so dumb that they make
fake artists with fake inspirations to
fulfill their backstory and then it's
not done there they then have to do a
fake giveaway to generate hype here's
gavin once again saying also you have an
alt we can give away to lol logan says
yeah gavin replies okay have it react
and we'll give away in a few hours in
other words the giveaway is fake they
give it to their friends but this
generates more hype for their project
now after all this happened this logan
character you're seeing here gotta to
feel a little bad about what he did he
was sorry about it he said in a
statement that this was simply a cash
grab that the actual two real owners
aren't travis at all but instead gavin
and gabe and the reason i'm showing you
this is this is emblematic of what they
would do every time they would need a
new front man for their schemes but
behind the scenes the people making the
real decisions were usually one of these
three gavin gabe or ali and they kept
needing new doxes to put as the front
man because every time one person was
responsible for a rug pull or scam they
needed a new guy in the future so they
couldn't be traced back gavin and gabe
got doxed on this project and then on
league of divine beings ollie got doxxed
so their identities were burned and they
had to start hiring new people to be the
public founders of a project basically
puppets and this is where our salon is
gonna come in our our young young kid
with braces on who says that he's all
about his morals and by the way just so
you guys understand these nft scams make
so much money that at one point gavin
rents out an office to do it from this
is what allegedly he was calling it the
nft factory quote also opening an office
and hiring people in real life so no
loose ends
bruh you got an office gavin responds
yeah gonna have ten plus people working
sales and on these projects gotta spit
out at least five to ten before it ends
so now that you have a basic
understanding of their pattern of
behavior we're gonna go back to
squiggles because this project was
looking to be their most lucrative one
yet it was going to be the most
expensive and had the most people
following it and hyped up about it 20
million dollars was potentially on the
line and everything was looking perfect
after doing this many times maybe
they've perfected the formula and all
they had to do was lay low but of course
they couldn't do it they decided that
success was almost assured and they
decided to go out and party and
celebrate this is where they screwed up
because turns out some pictures were
taken that night on instagram showing
arcelon the supposed founder of
squiggles and gavin together in the same
rolls-royce then later they appeared at
the same club holding a sign that said
squiggles boys and then a photo appeared
with gavin ali and gabe all in the same
photo pretty quickly people put two and
two together and hours before launch all
of this information came out going viral
that this super hyped launch is actually
coming from a bunch of serial scammers
so that brings us back up to speed to mr
morals here and i'm gonna let a
statement play again only a bit longer
now that you understand the context i'm
all about my morals uh people are just
trying to paint a picture that's not
true and they're trying to ferment fear
um i was at the club with friends of
friends who didn't have a good
reputation in the space um now they're
trying to tie me to them it's not how it
works guys please do not jump to
conclusions don't jump to conclusions
guys i was just at the same club i was
just in the same vehicle as them guys
it's just it's all a coincidence they're
just friends of friends and that maybe
would have been a good argument if
someone didn't almost immediately leak a
screenshot of gabe one of these guys
telling arseline quote you got an ama
coming up poppy better start preparing
and then even more all accusing gavin
ali and gabe of being behind this now
it's at this point you might think okay
so these guys are caught red-handed
they're screwed they're not gonna make
any money with this right but you'd be
wrong 30 minutes after launch seven
million dollars worth of squiggles had
been bought and honestly this really
disheartened me watching so many people
walk into what was so clearly a scam how
could they be this naive well maybe they
weren't is that seven million dollars
all real this is where things are about
to get a little weird see as i looked
closer at this seven million dollars
that was generated things didn't really
look right a lot of the buyers were
brand new and i was confused why could
it be that all of the buyers were brand
new to crypto i mean there were so many
that had never done anything on either
scan before and that's when i discovered
something a series of shadow wallets all
created by one person that were all
buying tons of squiggles millions of
dollars worth of fake volume and then
immediately flipping them on open c for
less money digging backwards i found a
single account that spent 800 ethereum
which is over two million dollars spread
across two transactions that created
hundreds of new wallets each of these
shadow wallets then bought three
squiggles apiece and immediately listed
them on openc for less money now you
might be wondering why do this why buy
two million dollars worth of squiggles
only to sell them for less who in their
right mind would do this well the only
reason that makes sense to me is they
were trying to give the illusion of huge
interest to get people to buy in to make
people think this had a lot of trading
volume a lot of hype the only people who
could possibly want to do that is of
course
the team behind squiggles although it's
worth saying they deny this saying it's
a hater trying to bring them down i
reached out to arsene the supposed
founder he didn't respond so where does
that leave us well it's currently
unknown how much of the squiggles seven
million dollars is fake volume created
by one account or real volume word from
anonymous sources is that they made
roughly three million dollars in profit
although i couldn't get anyone to go on
the record about this so we don't know
either way they were stopped from making
the 20 million dollars they could have
made and that's good less than 24 hours
later these guys got de-listed on openc
and their founder went private on
instagram but our story isn't quite over
yet because the team behind this isn't
exactly happy with how things went down
why would they be they potentially lost
millions of dollars so they're angry at
anyone who helped expose them this is
according to sources who started coming
out of the woodwork saying that this
team has begun to threaten them for
coming out according to one person quote
they told me they would send people to
my house and get my parents fired the
guy who exposed one of their older scams
said quote i was getting lawsuit threats
which were fake then it escalated to
threats against my family about getting
articles written and published that my
parents
children finally worst of all one
message said my private messages are
crazy but low-key fear for my life as
these guys put hits out i'm being deadly
serious now i want to be clear nothing
has happened that i know of and
hopefully these stay what they are right
now just threats however now that the
cat is out of the bag on how these guys
operate hopefully scamming will get
harder for these guys and many people
will realize that behind that cool new
shiny nft project created by some cool
artist who's doing nfts for the first
time there may be more behind the scenes
than you realize and maybe one day the
feds will get involved and put a stop to
this stuff but until then gavin is still
hiring for the factory
that's it for now subscribe pump the
stock i'll see in the next investigation